in this work we designed and evaluated a
shared gaze visualization to support
communication between remote power
programmers we developed a novel gaze
visualization for visual studio that
displays where your partner is looking
as a rectangle on the Left margin of the
screen it turns green when you're
looking at the same thing based on
observations with pair programming teams
we identified problematic areas for
remote pair programming we focus on the
issue of effectively referring to and
communicating about locations in the
code when you cannot see what your
partner is looking at therefore we
address the research question how does
the spline gaze awareness affect how
remote pair programmers refer to
locations in the code we conducted a lab
experiment with 12 groups of pair
programmers in a pseudo remote setup the
programmers are in the same room so they
can communicate freely but they cannot
see each other the screens are mirrored
and scrolling is yoked the programmers
are looking at the same window and can
edit in real time we use it within
subjects design in which pairs can edit
the code with and without the gaze
awareness visualization you will see in
the following clip two programmers
working together keep in mind that the
gaze of the participant in the upper
right is displayed on the screen in the
lower left and vice versa
so they think we should do this you
should be issued I think it should be as
it is this guy
so be there you hear you talk about
anywhere else so we can say you know
it's very closest here
great the results of this study suggests
that the shared gaze visualization
improved communication between remote
power programmers the chart on the Left
shows the fraction of time that
participants looked at the same place in
the code the black bar on the Left shows
when the gaze visualization was
displayed while the red bar on the right
shows when the visualization was not
displayed you can see that when the gaze
visualization was displayed pairs looked
at the same place in the code about six
percent more often than when the
visualization was not displayed his
result is significant according to an
ANOVA test the chart on the right shows
the types of references made by
participants for more implicit
references on the left such as deictic
references or saying here for this two
more explicit references on the right
such as highlighting sections of code we
see that when the gaze visualization was
displayed participants used more
implicit references compared to using
more explicit references without the
gaze visualization the suggest that the
visualizations supported more efficient
communication by allowing pair
programmers to use less specific
language when referring to locations in
the code pairs were also faster and more
successful at acknowledging references
with the gates visualization
additionally we see that changing the
bar color to green enabled pairs to
understand when they were looking at the
same thing as their partner at the same
time we would like to thank microsoft
research for supporting this work